okay so now we turn to a big topic when
you use datastore queries
and we will start by giving you an
overview of the types of queries that we
will run
let's do that by looking at conference
central where we will build out the show
conferences function
in the first tab here we can see all
conferences
this query is called query by kind
because we will search for all entities
which are of the conference kind
in the second tab we can see all the
conferences created by the user
this query is called query by kind
filtered by ancestor because we will
search for all conferences that have the
user as their ancestor
remember this is the ancestor
relationship we established between the
conference and the profile that created
the conference
and finally in the third tab we will see
all conferences the user has registered
to attend
this query is called query by kind
filtered by property because we will
display all conferences that are in the
attended conference property of the
profile entity
remember this is the has a relationship
we created between a profile and the
conferences they register to attend
and one more thing in this part you can
further restrict the search results by
applying filters
and as you can see from the drop down
menu these are properties in the
conference kind so therefore this will
also be a query by kind filtered by
property
okay so these are the query types we
will look at now query by kind query by
kind filtered by ancestor query by kind
filled by property
the query by kind filtered by property
is a little bit advanced stuff
the other ones are pretty
straightforward though so you'll start
off by adding them to conference central